so for insight on the left sharp turn
away from civility in politics
let's bring in Fox News contributor Mike
Huckabee host of Huckabee on Saturday
and Sunday by the way on TBN and former
governor of the great state of Arkansas
all right gov you gave me some good news
on my radio show on Monday
you you broke it that that that red hen
manager walked across the street with a
group of people and followed your
daughter or your daughter's family cuz
she was already gone to another
restaurant so they can't apparently
can't eat anywhere period but now you
see Steven Miller being targeted with
these wanted posters which again incites
people to do what when someone's wanted
for crimes against humanity
what are you telling other people to do
to him that's my question to you well I
think you know if we go back to Mayberry
RFD you'd start hearing Gomer Pyle yell
citizens arrest
citizen's arrest but you're almost
asking people to do is intervene as if
Steven Miller has done anything that
violated the law he didn't he's a policy
guy you labeled him pretty well
a moment ago not very complimentary in
some ways but pretty accurately
he's a very nerdy policy guy brilliant
beyond brilliant but he is no screaming
kind of guy he is a you know nose to the
grindstone sort of fella but when this
becomes personal and people take it away
from the public venues of a town hall or
a speech in public at a university
campus and they start taking it to
people's homes and they start making it
so that a person like Pam Bondi can't go
see a mr. Rogers movie or so that my
daughter can't even go and even get to
the appetizer because the moment she
gets there the manager tosses her out
and tells her to leave I mean that's the
kind of thing we saw at lunch counters
in the 60s and I thought we were never
gonna see that again it's it's pretty
sad had Sarah thought and you know you
always think in retrospect what if she
was just so flesh didn't want to make a
big stink of anything so she just left
but she ever think maybe maybe I should
have stayed I think of those Starbucks
those african-american men at Starbucks
they decided to stay let the police come
I mean my tenants do to say okay you
want me thrown out you guys bring the
police to throw me out it's a public
place you
she think that and retro no I don't
think so because my daughter is not the
kind of person who was raised to be
disruptive she really wasn't she was she
doesn't have this attitude that as
people owe her something she honestly
believes that the lady doesn't want her
there then why should we want to stay
but I do think her attitude was I could
stay and make a scene sure I could
demand that she served me but to what
end how does that serve a growing level
of civility the truth is it doesn't so
when the manager made it clear that she
wanted her to to exit the restaurant she
did it quietly and she did it politely
that's the way Southern women do things
they don't disrespect others Laura as my
mother used to say when we did something
that was not very nice were you raised
by wolves and I look around and I
realize there's some people in this
country who yes seemed to have been
raised by wolves
rather than mothers and fathers who
taught them good manners now Sarah got I
understand she has a Secret Service
detail on now with her that was
announced today and my question is is
she gonna be dining out in Washington
anytime soon oh she is she you know
feeling like she doesn't want to put
herself through this or her family
through this again yeah I can't confirm
about the detail because I haven't heard
it from her I saw it on Twitter tonight
first I had seen that if so you know two
things I'm glad I think she needs it in
light of Peter Fonda's comments when he
said he hopes someone would break into
her home and kidnap her children I'll
tell you Peter Fonda ought to be in jail
tonight and I mean that sincerely
the man ought to be in jail for having
said that kind of thing but I think
Sarah's gonna live her life as best she
can but you know one of the things this
is doing Laura it's giving Republicans
and Democrats a real message clarity as
we move into the election season and
here's the way I see it quite frankly
for Republicans every day is the 4th of
July for Democrats every day is
Halloween and America will get to decide
whose message do they want to follow the
celebration of freedom are throwing
eggs at people's homes yeah it's
pathetic I mean if it's sure on the
other foot there'd be there'd be it'd be
massive protests against this type of
behave